welcome back to CBS mornings to many
Americans China is not only a global
competitor but also a potential
adversary where one man is all-powerful
that is President Xi Jinping whose
speech to the Chinese Communist party's
National Congress yesterday showed his
iron grip on the party it's set to
rubber stamp his continued rule as
supreme leader making him the most
powerful Chinese leader since chairman
Mount Elizabeth Palmer has the story
from Hong Kong Liz good morning
good morning until now term limits had
kept Chinese leaders to no more than 10
years in the job but Xi Jinping has
managed to change those rules and that
tells you something about just how
powerful he's become
here's a man ready to command the
country and the future
and if any of the 2300 delegates here
don't like it they wouldn't say
Xi Jinping in public anyway is never
wrong
in party propaganda like State TV's
fawning series The Navigator he leads
the way into a socialist Utopia
she's Cult of Personality recalls an
earlier one chairman miles the
Revolutionary despot who ran China for
almost 30 years
like Mao she's even put out a book and
yes there's an app too she Jinping
thought recommended reading for loyal
citizens
in it he analyzes Chinese governance but
what he doesn't explain is why he thinks
heavy-handed control and repression have
to be part of it
like facial recognition technology for
tracking people and a zero covet policy
that has locked down millions of Chinese
lives
Jeff Kingston lectures in Asian politics
at Temple University in Tokyo what makes
Xi Jinping tick well
nobody really knows what makes him tick
there are Clues his parents were
communist Elites but in the 1960s his
father was denounced during Mao's
Cultural Revolution and young she was
exiled to a poor Village for
re-education I think he was very much
influenced by his childhood experience
and seeing the politics of the cultural
revolution and how it suddenly could you
know hit you even if you're a privileged
family but she came back and climbed the
party ranks until he got to the very top
what we see as a much more aggressive
assertive saber-rattling hegemonic
policy he sees as a patriotic policy
consistent with his vision of a Great
China for she a Great China includes
Taiwan and he told delegates he'd take
control of the island preferably
peacefully but he would not renounce
Force
she's facing headwinds though a real
estate crash growing U.S military
presence in the region and even internal
dissent there was a rare glimpse of that
last week on a Beijing overpass a banner
that read we want food not coveted tests
and she is a dictator
it was of course taken down in a hurry
but it was an uncomfortable reminder to
Xi Jinping that repression and control
can fuel dissent as well as snuff it out
Tony
Elizabeth Palmer for us in Hong Kong Liz
thank you very much